ça fait dix ans et 4 mois que les états
unis sont en croissance et un record de
longévité
ce cycle économique est le plus long
depuis 1854 et les signaux de la
récession le king a pas très fort en ce
moment francis généreux économiste chez
desjardins économiste principal bonsoir
francis généreux
c'est vraiment la plus longue période
depuis avant abraham lincoln c'est quand
même incroyable tout à fait on a des
données depuis le milieu du 19e siècle
et donc il va beaucoup de 6800 un peu
moins des années 1900 minute quand même
pas mal on eu quelques grands cycles
récemment dont l'ancien plus long qui
était celui des années et des années 90
sous la clinton avec la bulle des
technos tout ça mais maintenant oui
depuis l'été dernier on a maintenant le
aux etats-unis le plus long cycle on va
regarder un graphique que vous avez
préparé si la durée des phases de
croissance des cycles économiques aux
etats-unis le cycle actuel en hausse en
24 mois de 91,2 mais là on avait eu 120
mois oui tout à fait le sens 24 mois ou
si ça va être 125 dans quelques jours
une fois que le monde avant mais terminé
on va racheter un plus haut à notre donc
on continue à avancer dans le temps et
ce qu'on voit souvent des cycles des
années 70 ces années 90 ce soir on a
beaucoup comparé les dernières années
mais
et après on nous dit c'est quand même
plus court la cour avant la crise 2001 à
2007 avant la crise étaient 73 mois donc
avec une négociation due à la chute de
l'écrasement d'avion des techno leur en
2000 2001 la récession se terminer assez
rapidement mais le site n'a pas été long
par monsieur par ailleurs on a
l'impression que ce 124 la 125 personnes
a été dispersée en 28 combats le
prolonger on va regarder d'autres
graphique que vous avez préparé sur la
croissance des indicateurs économiques
croissance de l'emploi et du revenu réel
également ce qu'on a fait dans notre
étude c'est vraiment répertorié
plusieurs indicateurs on a dix huit
indicateurs qu'on veut qu'on vérifie à
chaque mois pouvoir ouest où sont les
signes ou est-ce qu'on pourrait voir
s'il ya une récession pas et quelques
indicateurs comme ceux ci seront des
indicateurs très importants que le nbr
qui l'organisent qui officialise les
créations aux états unis utilisent et on
voit que le marché de l'emploi est
maintenant dix ans qu'il n'y ait pas eu
de baisse d'emplois même une petite
baisse mensuelle on a pas eu dans le
dernier cycle donc 22 millions peu près
d'emplois créés depuis 2010 c'est quand
même bon cycle d'emplois on le trouvait
long surtout ses débuts avec les
dernières années depuis depuis
maintenant plusieurs années la
décroissance d'emploi sont quand même
relativement bas 2017 il y avait 146
millions d'emplois 2010 848 et là on est
rendu à 152 en 2020 voyez que la ligne
de création d'emplois poursuit
oui et une chose pour les revenus qu
évidemment emplois génèrent du revenu
les salaires maintenant qu'ils sont
aussi plus présents depuis quelques
temps 3% de croissance cette année sur
année donc on voit que les revenus là
aussi c'est assez intéressant donc pas
vraiment d'inquiétude les ménages
continuent à faire de l'argent donc
n'ont pas coupé leurs dépenses et donc
se sentent assez confiance dans cette
mesure deux autres indicateurs
économiques que vous avez apporté sur
l'industrie et sur les ventes également
donc la production industrielle là par
exemple ça s'est calmé un peu oui
exactement sont pas faits rapidement au
ventre et elles m'ont voir que là aussi
ça va assez bien les gens du revenu donc
on peut y achète dont les ventes
d'entreprises vont c'est bien
le hic il c'est là qu'on voit les
problèmes présentement dans l'économie
américaine mais aussi dans l'économie
mondiale c'est que la production
industrielle elle tout bonnement plus au
ralenti et le grand coupable de cette
situation là c'est la guerre commerciale
grosso modo la guerre commerciale qui
fait ralentir le commerce mondial sur
l'ensemble de la planète mais les
problèmes si directement avec les os de
taille est forte la chaîne les états
unis amènent production industrielle
beaucoup plus faible on a vu beaucoup
dans l'équipement secteur automobile qui
va un petit peu moins bien aussi partout
sur la planète
mais on voit vraiment sait où est ce
qu'il ya une faiblesse présentement aux
états unis c'est vraiment dans ce
secteur manufacturier et on le voit dans
d'autres indicateurs
j'ai parlé tantôt en dépit d'indicateurs
mais tous les indicateurs qui sont comme
plus touché le secteur manufacturier
e on les voit baisser présentement je
vais préparer un texte qui sera diffusée
ce soir ou demain matin sur votre étude
parce que vous utilisez 18 indicateurs
et en 2008 jeu savant la grande
récession 10 des 18 signalant une
récession est tout à fait autorisé
didier à ce moment là qu'on s'en allait
vers une décroissance que vous ai dit
que pour le mans compte après avoir des
baisses du pib qui s'en venait
effectivement eu une onu on en voyait
peut-être pas de temps au club ce que
l'arrestation en fait quand même
beaucoup plus mal à cause des amplitudes
de la crise financière s'est ajoutée à
la situation qu'on voyait des jeunes en
économie mais oui cela semble être des
signes assez probant pour le moment tant
mieux non n'est pas tant que ça là vous
envoyer 4 sur 18 4 sur 18 donc ce n'est
pas une situation très inquiétante
encore on va continuer de surveiller
parce que comme j'ai des signes de
faiblesse notamment de sacrés
manufacturier mais tant que l'emploi
elle attaque les ménages demeure
confiant on peut s'attendre ce que le
cycle ceux contenus dans les prochains
mois face
mais est ce assez calme mais aussi un
nouvel indicateur que les économistes
suivent c'est à dire les recherches sur
google j'ai un nouvel indicateur peut
être ça fait plusieurs années là mais on
regarde les recherches qu'on a vu quand
nous 2019
il y avait une forte recherche du mot
récession oui tout à fait ça devenait un
peu avec le marché financier en même
temps que les taux d'intérêts nous ont
montré une inversion d'apprendre de
coupe de grandes marques est un des
indicateurs
ça fait qu'il ya eu beaucoup plus
d'inquiétudes dans les gens qu'ils
gardent beaucoup plus près des marchés
aussi la bourse qu'elle est moins bien à
cause de nouvelles phases de la guerre
commerciale entre les états unis de la
chine
donc tout ça mis ensemble on a commencé
à s'inquiéter un petit peu plus
d'arrestations on l'a vu dans les
recherches
on l'a vu dans d'autres éléments mais on
est on le sent très atypique étude de
plus qui commence à s'essouffler
donc pas de récession là en vue aux
états unis gagne films comme en poésie
alors il ya une certaine faiblesse non
sinon une fragilité plus que nous faire
plaisir et on sent qu'il ya une certaine
fragile d'estantens acteurs comme les
manufacturiers et pas tellement fragile
et il faut ça prend des parts contre
autre chose pour faire tomber l'économie
en récession tac le secteur des services
qui lui est assez forte à que les
consommateurs sont assez confiants
mons-hainaut aussi confiant de pouvoir
de des récessions mais un choc pour
arriver on sait de andry de trous de ou
une escalade de la crise
la guerre commerciale pourra causer plus
de problèmes français généreux merci
pour cette analyse